so i want to start today talking about
inflation
um we are now starting to see inflation
rise more quickly than it has in quite
some time
and republicans are going absolutely
crazy thinking that this vindicates
their 30 years of claims that oh no
now that the government has done some
stimulus
we are going to see this inflationary
spiral
which will destroy the economy they've
been saying it for 30 years and it
hasn't happened
and now they are turning this recent
new employ uh inflation number not
employment number
uh into what they claim is a vindication
of the claims they've been making for
the last 30 years
and somehow this also relates to joe
biden and we're going to get back to
that in a moment but
i think it's important to understand the
kind of context here uh the us
has been i guess you could say the word
is blessed
with very low inflation for a long time
steady but low
inflation uh the way most economists
believe
is ideal for an economy and we'll talk
about why
a little bit later the consumer price
index has now
increased in april compared to a year
earlier by
4.2 percent and this is the most in a
year-over-year comparison dating all the
way back to september
of 2008 so in about 13 years when we
compare
uh one month in one year to that same
month the year before this is the
biggest change we've seen about in the
last 13 years
economists surveyed by dow jones were
looking for an increase of 3.6 percent
it came in above that at 4.2 percent
now this is really really important to
understand before we even get into the
macroeconomic analysis
i do think we are seeing some prices
truly increase in some areas lumber for
example
as far as the research i've done shows
lumber is getting more expensive
in a real way not just because
of a pandemic-related statistical
artifact
but much of this uh increase
is merely a pandemic-related statistical
artifact uh gas prices
for example going up in late 2020 and so
far in 2021
aside from this temporary pipeline
shutdown which is being resolved uh
is is back on as as of today um
we saw one of the biggest demand
collapses for gasoline
in 2020 because the country shut down
people weren't driving people weren't
commuting
and then relative to that we saw a huge
demand increase
later in 2020 and particularly in 2021
so the numbers we just received for
inflation
are april of 2021 compared to april of
2020
in april of 2020 we had one of the
biggest macroeconomic
demand collapses in a very long time i
can't
i don't remember when we had such a
demand collapse because it was the first
full month of covet shutdown so prices
collapsed now we are comparing to april
of 2020 and so when you look at the
internals of what's driving this price
increase its energy prices again
hugely demand driven oil prices
collapsed in the second quarter of 2020
where at one point oil futures had even
gone negative
now people want to travel again people
want to drive people want to fly
used car and truck prices are up which
makes sense as some people
are going back to commuting one car
families are going back to two cars
all of the people who got their first
who would have gotten their first jobs
and potentially gotten a car during the
pandemic
uh but were either working from home or
didn't even get that first job until now
many of them now need vehicles to start
getting to and from work so this is
primarily what we call
a base rate effect when we compare
inflation
last month to inflation at a time when
lots of prices had collapsed
you are going to see a relative price
increase that may not really be
representative of
what is going on in the economy now the
good news is that the fed seems to know
this and has said
we're not going to do anything in the
immediate as a result of these inflation
numbers
one month of numbers with the heart of
the pandemic as the base number that
we're comparing to april of 2020
it really doesn't give you much to work
with the inflation
target remains two percent for the year
the fed still expects that
yearly inflation year over year
will be roughly two percent so for now
the fed isn't going to raise rates
they're not going to make any other
changes now that all being said
there are actual shortages of some
construction materials
that will probably remain for the
foreseeable future and that's going to
cost more renovations are going to cost
more
new home prices may well cost more now
let me address a couple of other bigger
picture things
first you might be saying david sir
why is the target two percent inflation
like why is some inflation better than
none shouldn't we be targeting
zero inflation this is a very debated
economic issue
but fundamentally if you have deflation
or you have stagnant prices meaning no
change whatsoever
it's an incentive for people to wait to
purchase things
now this is a standard economic analysis
if you want to apply a totally different
line of thinking to the economy a more
socialistic line of thinking communistic
of course you're going to have a
different perspective but in the kind of
traditional economic thinking
which is of course only partially right
we know now that
classical economics is only tells us
part of the story
the idea is if you think things will
cost more in the future
you are incentivized to buy them now
before the prices go up you get it for
less now and you can start using it now
why would you wait
that is where growth and employment and
wages come from
uh if you think things will be cheaper
in the future or at least that they
won't be more expensive
you might wait to see if prices go down
and then it creates a deflationary
spiral because you're waiting to buy
prices do go down businesses have to lay
people off since they're not
selling stuff because remember you're
waiting to buy
they don't have the the employees that
get laid off don't have money to buy
stuff so prices go down more
and you can have what's called a
deflationary spiral japan experienced
this for
a long period of time it's neoclassical
at basic economic thinking
but that's part of the working theory
obviously too much inflation is bad
because then people's purchasing power
goes down they can't afford stuff either
so
that's where you get to this kind of
happy medium of we want a little bit of
inflation
and predictably so now last thing on
this
republicans are now claiming vindication
we told you
the stimulus would make prices go up and
things would get unaffordable
they said this when biden did the 1.9
trillion stimulus
they didn't say this when trump did both
of his
stimulus packages they have been saying
it for 30 years including in 2009 when
obama did tarp etc etc
the truth is inflation throughout all of
that government spending
has been very well controlled and very
modest and very reasonable
this seems to be primarily an artifact
of comparing numbers
to the absolute lull the doldrums of the
pandemic
uh and that's it there's there's really
i'm finding myself not even really
having more to say
uh about that piece because it is so
transparently untrue so that's the
latest on inflation
we'll watch the numbers we will soon
have numbers in early june we'll have
numbers comparing
may 2021 to may 2020 and then we'll have
to
uh at that point we'll be able to get a
more well-rounded picture of what's
going on
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign
up at privacy.com slash pacman